good morning Hank it's Tuesday so hey
today marks the sixth anniversary of
vlogbrothers but more importantly last
night the United States Senate through
the worst New Year's Eve party ever that
ended with a compromise to avoid the
so-called fiscal cliff of increased
taxes and decreased spending the
centerpiece of this compromise is to
make the really hard decisions in a few
months so Congress John from the future
here quick update when making this video
I naturally assume that the House of
Representatives would also agree to the
compromise so as to avoid intentionally
throwing the nation into a recession but
it turns out I may have been overly
optimistic Congress by almost any
measure the last two years have seen the
least effective Congress in the United
States since at least the 1850s which as
you might remember led to a Ken Burns
documentary maybe the last two years the
US Congress has only passed 219 bills
which may sound like a lot except to
almost all of those were to name federal
buildings after war heroes I mean don't
get me wrong I am happy that there is
now a post office named after
Revolutionary War general Nathaniel
Woodhull who in order to say god save
the queen' instead said god save us all
and then got killed but that's it Hank
that's all they've done I mean the
famous do-nothing Congress with the
Harry Truman era passed more than 900
bills so I understand why the
legislative branch has become so
incredibly ineffective at legislating we
need a quick history lesson the original
American government was founded on the
Articles of Confederation and that
government really couldn't do anything
so we eventually had to ditch the
articles and write the Constitution
which created a congress that could do
you know just a little bit so the United
States Congress like a lot of rich
people lives in two houses there's the
Senate which has two members from each
of the 50 states who are elected to
six-year terms and then there's the
House of Representatives where people
serve do your terms which means they're
basically always campaigning each state
gets a certain number of Representatives
based on population so like Hank in
Montana you just have one because no one
lives in Montana here in Indiana we have
like nine and vitally each state
legislature draws its own lines for
where the congressional districts begin
and end and Hank I think that turns out
to be one of the central reasons why
Congress can't do anything Hank my
Congress person here in Indianapolis is
Andre Carson he's a Democrat my
across-the-street neighbor however is
represented by a Republican named Dan
Burton is that because we live in
different zip codes no we live in the
same zip code it's because the houses
across the street are more expensive so
they redrew the district to include
those houses because they figure the
vote for Republicans and I think this
kind of thing is happening all over the
country like according to analysis by
Nate Silver in the last 20 years we've
gone from 103 swing districts that is
districts where either party
about an equal chance of winning 235
swing districts and today because of the
way state legislatures draw these maps
most congressional districts are
so-called landslide districts which
means there are at least 20% more
Republican or more democratic than the
American population Hank if you're
Democrat Andre Carson or Republican Dan
Burton you're going to win your general
election by like 30 percentage points so
in most congressional elections the race
between the Republican and the Democrat
is not a race the only race the only
thing these people have to fear is a
primary challenger another Republican or
another Democrat coming in and saying
you're not radical enough so why would
you compromise when compromising can
cost you your job
hey 2012 was an amazing year for us you
co-created the Lizzie Bennet diaries in
scishow and crash course VidCon doubled
in size my book The Fault in Our Stars
was published and so far has spent 51
consecutive weeks on the New York Times
bestseller list why are these things
happening because governments also
nerdfighteria government a there's a
reason why no popular YouTube adaptation
of Pride and Prejudice has emerged from
Somalia they don't have a government
they don't have roads to facilitate
commerce or public schools to teach kids
or investment in Telecom to make this
happen
so hey Congress was designed to suck at
doing stuff and they do but they have to
work together just enough to cover you
know the basics and we've always gotten
there but now I'm gonna worried now hey
people won't lose faith in America's
ability to govern itself all at once it
won't be an event it'll be a process but
if it happens it will be much worse than
going over any fiscal cliff so remember
the next time you vote the most
important direction might be for like
state Congress person or whoever's going
to draw the line to decide whether my
neighbor and I should have the same
congressional representation even though
we have different incomes Hank I'll see
you on Friday
p.s Hank who would have thought we'd be
doing this for six years Thank You
American government for running well
enough that I can make videos in my
basement for nerdfighters that sounded
creepy but it's not